good health now sponsored by partners in
primary care
partners in primary care hasn't been in
the valley long but they're already
making a difference i spoke to one of
their doctors about ways our seniors
can stay healthy this holiday season i
hear you guys are busy things are
you guys are getting more patience now
that we've been showing you all around
town
yes we are we're starting to get
patients and we're in open enrollment
right now so it's an exciting time
we love it and what is partners in
primary care just kind of give us a
brief introduction for people who don't
know yet
oh sure partners in partners in primary
care is a senior focused group
that just opened centers in las vegas we
opened
six offices currently we have spring
valley
fremont um north rainbow south rainbow
we have south nellis and southeastern
locations that are open
and in early 2021 we're going to have
two more locations one on west craig
and one in henderson so it's really an
exciting time now
yes especially when seniors need care
the most it's very important to keep
them safe and healthy
um what does senior focus care actually
mean let's define that
well seniors have different needs as
they age
and we are prepared to help patients
physically mentally socially with all
these special needs that they have
and we're we want to be your partner in
good health
and we even have special parking easy
parking to get into for our seniors
especially designed rooms for our
seniors everything is focused
so the patients get the care they
deserve they get to spend the time with
the doctor
that they need and the respect that they
deserve
oh that's great and of course during the
pandemic holidays are changing for
everybody
um how do you how do you suggest seniors
stay healthy during this time
well the holidays coming up of course
everybody thinks of food family and
friends and that is very important for
all of us to connect
however we are recommending the safest
thing is to stay home if you can
and the whole thing about staying
healthy
is trying to do the same things we've
been talking about now the cdc is
suggesting
to keep your family gathering small and
outdoors
they're also recommending if you are
going to be traveling a car is safer
than a plane
also make sure you don't have any covet
symptoms
for at least two weeks before you're
visiting anybody
and if you can stay home and quarantine
48 hours
before you do go visit with your family
is there anything else you want to add
absolutely if you are sharing dishes
with your family members during the
holiday
use paper plates if you can use plastic
utensils paper cups
also wash your hands frequently wipe
down
common areas where people are sitting
but also
wash your own dishes don't ask help from
your family to come
so this way you're involved you're
reducing the cross-contamination that
may occur
so even though grandma might want to
help you do the dishes
let her sit down and enjoy the pie
instead
good advice right there for more
information call 702-623-3770
or visit seniorfocuslasvegas.com we'll
be right back on las vegas now